[Music]
[Applause]
there is it a burner raging in
washington washington needs more doers
and innovators that's why I'm running
for US Congress
[Music]
you lost I will beat joe manchin and
ditch cocaine Mitch for the sake of the
kids
I need six more years to complete my
mission
thank you
then mr. Trump said you're fired
I love that part ever thought we'd be
saying this but Bigfoot erotica has
become a campaign issue this new drawing
of Bigfoot is from the Instagram account
of Denver Riggleman he's a Republican
running for Congress in Virginia his
opponent Democrat Leslie Cockburn
thought voters should know and publicize
them
[Music]
the Russian Federation is proud to
endorse Dana Rohrabacher for Congress
you are a true Russian hero
[Music]
America needs more leaders like Donna
who recognized that the world is better
off with a stronger bolder and
ever-expanding Russian Federation
Donna's our man
you